hi there steve kaufman
talking about languages again
there are many myths in language
learning one of the most damaging is the
idea
that past a certain age we can no longer
learn languages or adults can't learn
languages or as you get older your
ability to learn languages deteriorates
diminishes
not true
it might be
theoretically or somebody might
demonstrate scientifically that
neuroplasticity declines
but you can still learn okay you might
have learned faster at the age of 20 and
a little more slowly at the age of 50
although that has not been my experience
my experience has been that i learned
better now than i when i was 20 because
i had i know how to learn better i'm
more confident now and of course there's
so many more
uh you know resources available to help
you learn so
the reason i raised this subject is
because apparently there was a study
done in a magazine called cognition
which sought to demonstrate they did
some tests which i don't fully
understand but
the result of which the conclusion was
that we can't learn languages to fluency
after the age of 10. all right so let's
start right there and and by the way
this was picked up by time magazine and
by the guardian in england all right
i was at the long fest festival de long
in montreal where you had 400 poly lots
i addressed them and i asked these 400
polyglots in this big you know
auditorium i said how many of you grew
up in a bi in a multilingual family in
other words we're in a situation where
you were hearing lots of languages i
think one or two people put up their
hands so overwhelmingly these several
hundred people learned these languages
as adults and they many of them spoke
five six ten plus languages so it's not
just me and it's the same when i visit
the polyglot gatherings in europe most
people learn most of their languages as
adults
now
in the time magazine they quote the
study and talk about how you know that
they
quizzed people on their reaction to
certain english phrasing and that this
would demonstrate that they were either
you know german speakers or french
speakers or whatever uh fluency as i
said before if you are a german speaker
speaking english there's a high
probability that there are certain
phrases that will reflect your german
like i said you know i've been living in
canada since many years i can hear
people say that to me in flawless
english people who have wonderful
pronunciation who can read any novel in
the book who are totally conversed in
the language and there are certain
structures that somehow are they're
stuck with whatever came to them from
their native language so what they're
still fluent speakers of the language
all right uh in the guardian article
about this cognition
study
the fellow says you know i'm not going
to accept that
i can't learn i'm going to go try and
learn and then he spends the rest of the
article talking about duolingo
duolingo is not going to get you to
fluency duolingo is sort of an initiator
if you are
not strongly motivated to learn you can
get onto duolingo do some very basic
simple things and have the impression
that you are getting
a bit of a not even a toehold but a bit
of an entry into the language ultimately
if you want to learn you're going to
have to expose yourself to lots and lots
of content and this is the other thing
that's missing whenever they talk about
what you can learn as an adult or
whatever they always look at people who
study at schools you don't learn a
language in a classroom
as manfred spitzer
famous german neuroscientist whom i
often quote said we don't learn
languages in a classroom we learn
languages in our brain so the question
becomes how do we get the language into
the brain and this comes down to how do
we motivate people
how do we motivate people to do enough
with the language in the language so
that the brain starts to get used to the
language that needn't be
limited to what happens in the classroom
in fact what happens in the classroom
what's most important there is to what
extent can the teacher or the classroom
environment stimulate encourage guide
support
and make the learner want to learn the
language independently make the learner
want to spend enough time listening and
reading in order to make some progress
and that reminds me of another
thing that i saw on twitter where
stephen krashen said apparently that
there's a lot of talk on the internet or
amongst teachers and saying you know you
should have ninety percent target
language in the classroom
and stephen creston says it doesn't
matter if the 90
target language is incomprehensible to
the student it's not doing them any good
what's more important is
can you get the learner to commit
themselves to doing enough listening and
reading in the language and in that
regard the teacher using the learner's
language sometimes to explain sometimes
to translate sometimes to encourage all
of this can be very valuable because
the most most of the learning will take
place outside the classroom if the
learner is willing to engage with the
language listen read and do things in
the language so and if a learner is
prepared to do those things it doesn't
matter if the learner is eight years old
12 years old 20 years old
60 years old 72 years old it doesn't
matter we can learn
at whatever age
and by the way whatever our nationality
i don't believe that certain national
groups swedes or singaporeans or
ethiopians where there's a high degree
of multilingualism that those people are
naturally more gifted or that they have
some genetic predisposition to learning
languages anybody can learn if they have
the right attitude and if they spend
enough time at it and so
the classroom as sort of the model this
doesn't work because it didn't work in
the classroom is wrong yes ideally
immersion go to the country spend the
day talking to people whatever but
that's not practical for most people so
you create a world of immersion you
create a world of interesting
comprehensible content initially not so
interesting and then you build up to a
point where you can actually be doing a
lot of listening and reading on things
of interest and gradually the brain gets
used to the language so
is there an ideal uh age at which to
learn i don't think so and i wanted to
add one more thing because in this
discussion back and forth and you get
people saying well we just learned the
way kids learn and and the kids don't
read they learn anyway and stuff true
enough
but i can in six months
in most languages i can reach a level of
vocabulary in six months
that takes the child five years or
longer to achieve so the child may be
more fluent the child may pronounce
better but if we're talking about the
ability to communicate and understand
the language we can learn at any age and
we can learn to fluency fluency not
perfection thank you for listening bye
for now
[Music]
you